all right we begin with a huge shout out
to my biggest fan of all he's back
former president barack obama we might
actually have that beer finally i'm not
quite sure while he's why he's still
obsessed with me but today during his
first speech in quite a while brock once
again mentioned me i'm not exactly sure
why take a look
the researchers paid a large group
of regular fox news watchers
to watch cnn for almost a month
and the these were not
swing voters these these were hardcore
you know hannity
carlson fans right they're
they're right there
on some of these
issues their their views had changed by
five eight
ten points
these people didn't suddenly turn into
liberals
i i'm sure
they still
don't like me
but at the margins
they had reshaped their perspectives in
meaningful ways
by the way
president obama we don't hate you you're
just a horrible president your policies
are awful it's that simple
obama now is talking about a study it
was conducted by two obviously my view
guessing liberal college professors one
from berkeley and one from yale odds are
pretty high i'm right they paid fox
viewers to watch cnn for an entire month
i doubt it was a fair and balanced study
but it sounds like torture uh of course
once uh one big difference between fake
news c and n fox is we don't have to pay
people to watch this channel they
actually choose and we work hard to earn
your viewership in fact according to a
key demo data from nielsen uh more
democrats actually watch fox news than
cnn fake news or msdnc even barack obama
himself seems to continue to be a loyal
fox viewer after all little me and this
network have been on his mind for years
and we've got the tape to prove it take
a look
i'll put i'll put mr burgess up against
uh sean hannity
he'll tear him up i mean look um
is
sean hannity suddenly going to get on
the airways and say you know i was wrong
about this obama guy he's he's my man no
that's not going to happen i think that
there's a certain segment of hardcore
sean hannity fans that
probably wouldn't want to go have a beer
with me there's no doubt about that with
respect to sean hannity i didn't know
that he had invited me for a beer
his opinion of me does not seem to be
very high
but uh
but i'm always good for a beer i wasn't
viewed through this prism of
fox news and
conservative media and
making me scary and i haven't you know
turned on fox news or listened to
conservative talk radio yet today
but i've turned them on enough
over these past seven and a half years
to know i'm not exaggerating in terms of
their story look if i watched fox news i
wouldn't vote for me either right right
because you know you've got this screen
this fun house mirror through which
people are receiving information
perfect night to go back and reach back
into that uh the vault and bring out
some of these old tapes now we did reach
out to former president obama i did
invite him on this program it's an open
invitation mr president any night of the
week you can have the full hour we'll
even have beer during the show if you
like i'll pay for it i know socialists
like free stuff so you know if that's an
incentive for you i will pay for
everything i'll even pay for a state
dinner after
obama is now on a mission to combat he
says misinformation and disinformation
and this network has the largest reach
of any other outlet so i'm sure that
our viewers would love to hear his take
on hunter biden's very real laptop and
the very real money the biden family
made by selling out the obama white
house and i'm sure they'd love to hear
barack's take on why the media mob
breathlessly pushed hillary clinton's
dirty misinformation dossier and the
russia collusion hoax for years we got
it right they got it wrong i was right
about obama's radical associations he
didn't want to hear it i'm sure they'd
love to hear his take on disinformation
surrounding
justice kavanaugh the the verbal assault
and slander and smearing of nicholas
sandman the mostly peaceful violent
riots during the summer of 2020
574 of them kyle rittenhouse's hands up
don't shoot duke lacrosse uva freddie
gray baltimore or oh the cambridge
police acting stupidly and while we're
at it president obama why don't you tell
us how you really feel about our current
president joe biden because according to
politico hardly the vast right-wing
conspiracy you encouraged by not to run
you didn't want him to run wonder what
you knew that maybe other people knew
that maybe you cared more about him than
others i wouldn't be surprised if that
was the case obama once even reportedly
said quote don't underestimate joe's
ability to f things up and of course
obama doesn't want to answer any of
these questions that's because he's not
really interested in battling
disinformation instead
as you said today he wants to reshape
your perspective in other words he wants
all of you to be far left wing new green
deal democratic socialists like him
luckily the american people are more
intelligent than obama realizes which is
probably why the brand new uh effort of
fake news cnn called cnn plus was such a
massive failure now as you know the
ratings the networks ratings are
pathetically low and that's the free cnn
that you get with cable channels and yet
fake news cnn still spent they spent 300
million dollars on brand new a brand new
streaming platform that viewers could
only access with a paid subscription
okay naturally
predictably no one subscribed pretty
much no one and now cnn plus is
officially dead now this 300 million
dollar waste of money lasted all of 33
days as many twitter users rightly
pointed out a gallon of milk de blasio's
presidential aspirations kamala harris's
presidential campaign and seattle's
summer of love all lasted longer than
fake news cnn plus and apparently
americans were not willing to fork over
three whole dollars for a daily dose of
humpty dumpty or the occasional
interview from liberal swamp creature
chris wallace
apparently as it is americans get more
than enough fake news if they're not
watching the regular channel why are
they going to pay for an extra channel
anyway they get all the conspiracy
theories and vitriol they want from both
fake news cnn and msdnc 24 hours a day
look at our old friend nicole wallace
for example spent much of her life
pretending to be a republican she
actually helped run john mccain and
sarah palin's uh presidential run
she now gets paid by msdnc and she
pretty much spends every show smearing
republicans i'm fine i believe in free
speech that's okay now today she
actually compared governor desantis and
governor younkin to russian soldiers
raping children we have those comments
we'll play them coming up later in the
show now i asked lester holt chuck todd
chucky do you condone this kind of
rhetoric do you feel good about that
kind of rhetoric is that the kind of
news you support do you support your
colleagues do you support rachel
maddow's conspiracy theories and not to
be outdone one guest on one of these
shows that are low rated over there
compared i guess jesus to a groomer
really take a look
the entire message of the gospels of the
easter holidays was love one another and
i've said this before and i'll say it
again if jesus christ was alive today
he would be called a groomer
he would be called woke and he would be
called a socialist if he was alive today
no pushback an assault on christianity a
false narrative on christianity pretty
disgusting pretty bigoted uh not a word
we absolutely in this country as i said
have an information crisis i predicted
it said it in 2007 i've been more right
than i thought i'd ever be
journalism as dead buried and it has
been for quite some time the echo
chamber and the media mob they are
unyielding and yet obama other democrats
think that fox news is to blame if they
truly want to battle misinformation i
suggest they start at home hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else